el frío del otoño no es impedimento para
los manifestantes ya son 11 fines de
semana consecutivos de protestas en
belarús esta vez 100.000 personas se
tomaron las calles de la capital minsk
para seguir presionando al presidente
alexander lukashenko para que renuncie
la policía usó granadas de aturdimiento
para dispersar a los manifestantes que
habían dado una fecha límite de dos
semanas al mandatario para que
abandonara el cargo o irán a una huelga
general este lunes
duch a cinco ya había anunciado que
ignoraría el ultimátum hoy es el
ultimátum y a partir de las 11 59
nuestras condiciones deben ser cumplidas
por las autoridades yo apoyo a cada
ciudadano que está en las calles para
protestar de forma pacífica
desde el 9 de agosto los ciudadanos
protestan en contra de los resultados de
las elecciones presidenciales denuncian
que lukashenko manipuló los resultados
algo que él niega
lukashenko a presidir la nación europea
por más de 25 años y ahora con la ayuda
militar y económica de rusia muchos
creen que se atornillar a en el poder
infortunadamente creo que él lukashenko
no aceptará el ultimátum él vive en su
propio mundo y cree que mucha gente lo
apoya y que todos estamos equivocados y
que somos adictos a las drogas
prostitutas y vandalizado estatal ya la
unión europea eeuu reino unido y canadá
impusieron sanciones a funcionarios
acusados de fraude y violaciones a los
derechos humanos los principales
opositores al presidente lukashenko han
sido encarcelados o han huido del país